of course there are other stories fans
of the series would love to see two that
come up often are hey Mitch's Hunger
Games which are the 50th Hunger Games
and Phenix games which he won at 14
years old is the youngest Victor up to
that point while additional films of
this nature would satisfy the fan basees
want for more content once again it's up
to Collins to decide if we ever get to
see them as Francis Lawrence told ew
Suzanne always writes from a thematic
Foundation that's what makes them feel
rich and not superficial and I think
it's why they stood the test of time
honestly that means the future of the
film franchise rests in the hands of the
author the creative team is willing and
ready to bring more stories to life but
only if Collins is the one writing them
in a world where so many sequels are
made based on the money they could bring
in that's a refreshing perspective